more and more people are starting to buy
EGP use for their MacBooks to get an
extra boost in graphics performance for
things like video editing and gaming but
the question we're gonna answer in this
video is should you do it with the base
$1300 2020 MacBook Pro or the higher-end
$1,800 model to be completely honest
before doing this video we expected both
of them to be basically the same since
there isn't that big of a difference in
processing power because they both have
decent quad-core CPUs but we were wrong
you'll see why in just a minute now
before we get into our performance tests
I want to remind you guys of a few
different things buying an e GPU won't
do anything for programming photo
editing or Logic Pro 10 performance
since those tasks don't really use
graphics power and are instead heavily
dependent on processing power and RAM
and if you're interested in knowing the
best ways to get the most out of your
EGP you like using dummy adapters
instead of external displays make sure
to check out the video that we made last
week on this topic by clicking the end
screen button when this video is over I
also want to remind you guys of the e
GPU setup that we recommend which
includes the razor core x enclosure for
$300 and the 5700 XT graphics card for
380 dollars which will link to down in
the description below just in case you
decide to join the e GPU Club and
finally there were tons of people who
commented on the last video asking us to
connect the EGP you set up to the 16
inch macbook pro to test the performance
and I want to let you guys know that we
already did so I'll have a link to that
video after this video is over so
without further ado let's get into our
testing but before we get into the very
unexpected results we got for video
editing I want to show you guys the
difference in benchmarks and gaming in
the standard Geekbench 5 benchmark we
got basically the same score on both
MacBook Pros and that's because it's
measuring the raw power of the graphics
card so that's very good news for the
base model since by itself it scored
less than 7000 points we
has said units heaven gaming benchmark
and we got basically the same results
with both MacBooks but since those are
just benchmarks let's get into real
world gaming performance first we
started off with the relatively easy to
run league of legends with in Mac OS and
both setups were able to get an average
of around 140 FPS at 4k resolution with
all the settings maxed out so this game
was a cakewalk with no real difference
between both of these however we then
switched over to fortnight and this is
where we started to see a difference we
played at 1080p resolution at high
settings on both machines and the base
model with the GPU got an average of
around 65 FPS with the minimum fps
dipping down to 46 at times overall it
wasn't a smoother man experience as I'd
hoped for but it should get better if
you turn down some of the settings now
on the $1,800 MacBook Pro with the each
of you I noticed that gameplay was more
smooth in general with less frame drops
in dips than the base model with this
setup I noticed a much better 85 FPS
average with frame rates rarely ever
dipping below 60 fps so this gave in
actually great gaming experience on
these settings since you're at a minimum
of 60 fps almost all the time and one
thing I did notice is that on the base
model the fans were a little bit louder
as well now let's get into video editing
with Final Cut Pro 10 in the Bruce X
test we can see that the e GPU greatly
helped out the base macbook pro since it
took a very long 51 seconds by itself
but the $1,800 model would the a GPU
still beat it out by two seconds which
isn't that much however in our twenty
second 4k stabilization test the a GPU
was much slower with the base model than
with the $1,800 model in fact the
higher-end model by itself took only
four seconds longer than the base model
with the e GPU which is very impressive
and we honestly don't know what's
limiting the base model that much now
the first major discovery that we made
was during our five minute
que h.264 export test which is the codec
that most youtubers use the base model
with the e GPU was not only twice as
slow as the $1,800 model with a GPU but
it was even slower than that model by
itself which was totally unexpected one
thing we noticed during the export test
was that the fans on the base model were
much louder blowing at around 5,800 rpm
compared to a much quieter 4000 rpm on
the $1,800 model while connected to the
e GPU now we think there are two reasons
for this the $1,800 model actually comes
with dual fans compared to just one on
the base model so that's a pretty good
advantage but the even bigger deal is
that the $1,800 model comes with two
extra vents on the bottom side so when
you use your MacBook and clamshell mode
like most people do while using an e GPU
the fans can easily draw cool air from
those vents now since the base model
doesn't get those vents it doesn't get
cool air as efficiently so the single
fan has to work much harder to match the
cooling performance of the $1,800 models
dual fans and it ultimately runs louder
now back to that unexpected result in
the export test there's a chance that
the main limitation is actually the
eight gigabytes of Base RAM on that base
model but unfortunately we can't confirm
this right now because we don't have the
base model with the 16 gigabyte RAM
upgrade moving on to the five-minute 4kh
EVC export test we again saw the same
results with the $1,800 model by itself
being faster than the base model with
the e GPU which is just insane we took a
screenshot during this test to prove
that we have the 5700 XT graphics card
selected and this screenshot also shows
that for some weird reason the
integrated graphics on the base model is
being favored instead of the e GPU which
was weird because that didn't happen on
the higher-end
$1800 model the only reasonable
explanation is at the tension ship on
that higher-end model features new
technology that somehow improves the
efficiency of using EGP use like for
example
the PCH is now on package which
basically means it's integrated into the
CPU so maybe because of that the EGP you
can more quickly and easily communicate
with the processor and therefore boost a
GPU performance compared to the old 8th
gen champ now for our final video
editing test exporting a c200 raw 60fps
clip which has a much tougher codec to
work with the $1,800.00 pro with the a
GPU once again performed the best so
after running all of those tests we
figured out the best value options for
each different use case if you mainly
want to get some better gaming
performance the base model with an e GPU
should be fine for you but the $1,800
model did perform quite a bit better for
fortnight so if you can afford that set
up it's the best way to go since it'll
perform better than the 16 inch macbook
pro by itself now for 3d rendering or
other apps that mainly only use graphics
power
the base model should be just fine but
we strongly recommend spending the extra
$100 on the 16 gigabyte RAM upgrade and
finally for video editing we actually
recommend buying the $1,800 MacBook Pro
by itself without an e GPU because of
how well it performed beating out the
base model with the e GPU in a couple
different tests and later on if you feel
like it's still not fast enough for your
use case you can then invest into an e
GP you set up if you really want to but
keep in mind our results from our last
video we saw that the 16 inch MacBook
Pro by itself actually outperform that
$1,800 model combined with the e GPU
quite a few different times so if you
don't mind the larger size of the 16
inch MacBook Pro and you have the cash
to spend on it right now that is
actually the best choice for video
editing now I'm not trying to say that
the base model with the e GPU is bad for
video editing since it does a pretty
good job for a lot of the common 4k
editing tasks but it just doesn't
compare to the $1,800 model for those
who can't afford it so if this video
helps you make a decision on which one
to buy you can find the links to the Mac
books
in the EGP you parts down in the
description below and go ahead and tap
that like button and click the circle
above so you don't miss out on more
videos like this one and make sure to
check out those each of you videos right
over there those are the ones that I
mentioned earlier in the video thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]